and finally new rule Democrats must get
a good wedge issue to make sure they win
the next election and I have one in
minds hint
today is 4/20
the holiday we're stoners everywhere a
smoke weed to celebrate smoking weed
every other day of their life and to
celebrate it this year John Boehner yes
that John Boehner the weepy
chain-smoking Chamber of Commerce golf
course drunk who used who used to be
Republican Speaker of the House and who
used to say he was ultra bleah opposed
to decriminalizing pot just announced
he's evolved and he accepted a position
on the board of directors of acreage
holdings one of the largest legal pot
growers in the country wow you think
Boehner cried a lot before weightily get
stoned and sees a sunset
hey Democrats you're gonna lose this
issue if you're not careful because now
Republicans smell the money and
Democrats need this issue you know
there's a lot of talk now about how the
midterm elections are going to be a blue
wave blue wave sounds like an off-brand
aftershave at the dollar store
blue wave from the makers of Hillary
Clinton's inevitable no this election is
hardly in the bag especially considering
that when it comes to showing up for the
midterms Democrats are electorally
challenged what we need is a sweetener
to rouse the liberal base and I think
pot would do the trick now I could go on
and on about the benefits of weed
increased focus less anxiety better
sleep it makes food taste better music
sound better bad dates more tolerable
good for migraines glaucoma and the
nausea associated with reading Trump's
tweets
an eating pot increases levels of the
chemicals responsible for happiness oh
you're doing a heck of a job brownie yes
we love weed the way Republicans love
their guns every election Republicans
run on they're coming for your guns we
need to talk about weed that way and
turn pot heads into single issue voters
too it should not be that hard because
nobody's really coming for your guns but
Jeff sessions really does want to take
away your pot for which there is no
protection like the Second Amendment you
know we can bring those jobs back from
China but they're still gonna suck
you're at an Amazon warehouse for eight
hours with no one to talk to but the
robots you're gonna want that vape pen
Democratic politicians can talk all they
want about making college more
affordable but it's weed that makes it
bearable this should be an especially
potent issue for those younger voters
the ones we are so desperate to get to
the polls in November and those kids say
they're coming out for gun control
maybe but being against guns is not a
lifestyle guns is a lifestyle weed is a
lifestyle it's not just something you
have an opinion on it's in your home
it's a passion you like touching it
[Laughter]
guns and pot they have magazines about
it and so do we
they have gun shops we have dispensaries
they know the difference between
automatic and semi-automatic we know
that difference between indica and
sativa they rally around musicians that
support their cause even if they're
terrible and so do we
they have fancy ways to hide their stash
so do we
they like to have a zillion versions of
the same product so do we
come on there are gas masks bongs lava
lamp bongs penis bongs and the menorah
bong for those who celebrate chronica
look I tend to think guys who need a 50
caliber rifle to so they can shoot
through Ironman are crazy but then I
remember I once paid 3 grand for a
device called the mothership oh yeah
it heated hash oil to exactly 462
degrees in that a spherical doughnut
chamber with detachable bubbler and dual
wax ceramic coil and a 72 hole
percolator with matching showerhead ash
catcher did it make getting high any
better than using an apple no so why did
I drop three grand on it because I was
high when I ordered
[Applause]